guarda tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj e la devo
smettere
se avete lo discute forest quindi
partiamo elettrico fantastico arrivare
come entra bellissimo miglia come tratto
figo tipo rambo della serie che se devo
scappare mi devo uscire strisciando vi
prego accendi la luce che non vedo un
cazzo cazzo
ah ecco mica mezz'ora per capirlo
perfetto adesso dovrei riuscire a veder
minchia meno male che ci vedo è un po
rudimentale come come soluzione però
almeno vedo perché io non vedevo niente
posso anche usarlo come arma fantastica
permesso
sono fa vj vengo in pace e non scassa
temi le palle se provo a fare amicizia
salve
no no no non ho mai visto non ho visto
nemmeno visto a mano visto cazzo mar
affanculo e ho fatto ma allora vengo in
pace non correre zio non corre sono cosa
fai
non vi non mi picchiò nomi piva potrei
uccidermi 20 modi diversi ma non lo
faccio michele 7 meglio di quelli di
baywatch
[Musica]
io vado avanti vi giuro non vi cago
insicura che bravo che sono un amico
fidatissimo tra entrando solo perché
voglio prendere le robe tipo questo che
cassano è un cuore spero sia di mucca
non di uomo zio allora è ovvio sono
passato invece un tavolo stai calmo stai
molto molto calmo zio molto calmo molto
calmo
allora è che azzolini cioè non è
possibile che faccio un metro casa
giocando a un due tre stella fammi
capire a chi giuro che ti ammazzo
sociale flare non gli ha fatto un cazzo
lega non gli ha fatto proprio un cazzo
aiuto a ragazzi io tiro fuori lascia
perché ho paura che mi salti addosso
se vado piano non mi fa niente vero zio
thanei da braida vice taipei che cazzo
vuoi stronzo di merda con riva starr lo
muove è morto ho fatto casino non ho
fatto casino lo porterei volentieri
fuori per metterlo nel totem solo che
non so se ce la faccia uscire di qua
questo tizio vabbè andiamo avanti
salve ragazzi sta dormendo questi sono i
nuovi materassi eminflex sono invisibili
e sono verticali ti permettono di
dormire anche in piedi finché l'acqua mi
servirà tantissimo questa acquafresca
posso bere acqua azzurra era dare al
tema lo sveglio ce l'hai una bottiglia
per prendere l'acqua dai zio non c'è la
bottiglia
va bene almeno bebè vidali dio mio mi fa
venire 7 mettiamo lo so finito rega
aiuto siamo né nei cunicoli brutti nella
sua casa vedi che ci hanno proprio come
passione quella da arrampicata piquet
incredibile ma cos'è sta roba è un uomo
questo salve bello lei cos'è sarà una
bussola fantastico io prego iddio che
l'accendino si è limitato perché sono
veramente finisco male io sto pregando
di trovare un'uscita da un'altra parte
però mi sa che sto sbagliando di brutto
giorno o salve paziente abbiamo rilevato
tracce di mal di stomaco è a posto lei
si sente bene ragazzi di importante
quello delle palline portato delle
valigie per dio
oddio quanta roba quanto ben di dio ho
trovato dio santo catorcio però ancora
si nota ci sono anche le torce ragazzi
se riesco a trovarle posso mangiare uno
snack madonna avanti snack che ciò mi
ammazza nessuna mamma sono fuori e corna
che so che quando di queste cose
succede il peggio un'uscita che culo
vedo le stelle vai vai veloce non ci
credo mai a cristo
no non dimmi giorno sono farisei sarò
che bello vederla che bello che già mi è
andata di culi simo ma di culo in una
mania che non avete idea se spunta vaud
e c'era gente ero morto ma 20 voti bella
questa è arte e ragazzi apprezzate ma
sta gente qua che cosa ci faceva vestita
da tennis in una in un'isola deserta
fatemi capi non l'ho mai capita sta cosa
scusa non volevo scusate volevo scansare
la valigia io non ho trovato più una
torcia da quando gioca star omar appieno
una volta salve alla madonna quante sexy
cos'è 50 sfumature di zombie che figata
ragazzi veramente fan drink non ci
stanno i drink dentro ma avete mentito o
cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo
cazzo lo sapevo lo sapevo che merda ho
beccato l'albero vero veloce dove bambi
fai la guardia è brava brava bambi
bravissima ci credo mai ho visto un
occorrere me sembrava soldato a gambe
immediatamente avevo subito io mio
quant'è bello vedere casa sapete che li
miliardi di episodi che anni fa ho fatto
su the forest non mi è mai successo
nella mia vita di sopravvivere così
tanto e soprattutto di uscire da una
caverna così bene cioè senza morire la
madonna che cresce il cibo che figo
qua invece se avete la carne porca vacca
quasi direi che una pausini a me la
posso concedere tratro la vita è
pienissima non è mai scesa fantastico
prova a vedere se riesco ad ammazzare un
indigeno che a me non riesco a farmi il
totem mi porto un po avanti però non lo
troverò mai che quando mi servono li
vedo myst i deficienti
ecco l'acuto mica sono i due che culo
litro ricerca voli ho trovati tanto gli
faccio il culo entrambi allora non devo
morire non devo morire calmi
erano più di due non li avevo visti
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] no regala mi sono
sbagliato nel range e vabbè che cazzo
sono morto ci posso credere che sto
morendo [ __ ] [ __ ] capitana ma quanto
salti quanto mi sono curato vieni
bastardo vieni e sono ragazzi li ho
persi di vista tutti gli devo ammazzare
cosa fate
ma perché è perché l'hai fatto mi ha
salvato la vita si vede che sei
innamorata di me tesoro grazie l'hai
ucciso per chiamiamo in realtà vuoi
andare a casa mia a voi fare bunga bunga
amore mio non sapevo che mia massi così
tanto tanto da salvarmi la vita grazie
mi spiace averti colpita mi dispiace
perché allora sappiamo [ __ ] o ho
capito che sei in decisa perché le tue
cose ma cazzo deciditi posso prenderla
l'ho presa visto che è stata così
gentile dove spariscono i cadaveri sto
cazzo te la lascio lì fai quello che
vuoi
no scherzo ti devo uccidere luca quanto
mi dispiace
cioè mi posso fare il totem in questo
tizio si e se no non capisco come me lo
posso fare sto minchia di totem vuole
che bella l'ombra o si che funziona o la
testa c'è devi proprio farli a pezzi
tuffa questa cosa epica una gamba grazie
mille
varese isola qua possiamo aprire un
negozio di gambe vendo io ragazzini
manca un braccio e due teste ma testa
cielo lassù il braccio pure tanto non
serve un cazzo vero il culo perfetto via
ciao e stato bello dove diavolo el'altra
tizia trovata che culo gli animi negli
anni gli emiliani che bella cosa che sto
facendo ragazzi non guardate adesso
questo momento sintonizzatevi su hello
kitty tv e fate finta di guardare quello
sei mio amico george non fosse morto
vaffan cuore a quest'ora avrei già
completato un totem mi manca una testa
luridi maniaci non dovrei andare in giro
di notte lo so però mi serve una testa
ragazze
cioè io sto andando in giro in cerca di
una testa cioè questa la cosa bella di
sto gioco video in quale gioco andate in
giro cercando le teste di stronzo ma non
scherzavo soltanto magari se escono a
tirarne solo uno da milan da mensa sola
mensa stop società un'arma un po più
arma che dio mio così muoio subito
ragazzi miei
gli attuali visto che andavano di qua
prova a seguirli non so se riesco ci
provo ma non so quanto posso riuscirci
ditemi che sentita anche questo rumore
bruttissimo ma che cazzo succede lì no
no no no
quelli mi sa che quelli lì non li faccio
fuori lega cosa urli ma mi ha visto mi
ha visto come ha fatto a vedermi ma
malapena lo vedevo io succhia machaut si
è morto è morto è morto anche lui non è
morto invece o dovete morire cappero eva
però cosa vuoi dalla vita mia
sei tu che sei venuta a rompermi i
[ __ ] se stavi fermo non tiri rompevo
io che cosa fanno cosa o piange quanto
mi dispiace ma crepa deficiente se ti
facevi cazzi tuoi
ieri ha posto sempre venire a rompere
parole incredibili
no non mi serve questa grazie non dovrei
mangiare cose così a caso perché c'è il
rischio di avvelenamento altissimo però
mica sono tipo in mezzo alla foresta se
non mangio crepe non la torcia ecco
cos'era valori che non capivo hanno una
torcia le chiedevo ammazzarli dovevano
assurdo però se muoio perdo le teste
oddio con la molotov
non so quanto possa riuscire questo
piano ma ci provo
ciao ragazzi credo ragazzi spero che la
vita vi sia piaciuto in concluso b
l'episodio giocare di sera the forest
non è il massimo della vita ma foto e
gallo ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
come se viene preso dal momento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
nei video trovate in descriptions serie
di scatti ci vediamo al prossimo vino
bello ragazzi ora funziona sarò basi
funzionario